- What's up believe nation?
I made the Did You Know series
to try to learn a little bit more
about some of our famous entrepreneurs
and maybe introduce you
to a few surprising facts
you might find interesting.
So today, we're going to
learn nine surprising facts
about Kanye West.
(urban music)
(bell ringing)
Number one, Michael Jackson
told Kanye he could sing.
- What about Michael?
You talk about Michael all the time.
You did a remix for him.
Did you ever had an MJ personal encounter?
- Yeah, I sat with Michael Jackson.
I met him over Leonard Cohen's house
and I just vibed out with him
and then like, I think Michael the one
that want to put that battery
in my back to do 808s.
I played 'Good Life.'
And he was like, "Who's
that singing right there?
"I like that voice."
It was my voice, he gassed me up.
Next thing ya'll know, you have me
♫ In the night, I hear them talk.
Like, "Michael Jackson told me I can sing,
"fuck all ya'll."
(bell ringing)
- Fact number two,
Kanye originally went to
art school but dropped out
so he can do music.
- Originally I went to art school.
I had scholarships at
plenty of art schools.
Everybody thought I was
going to be an artist.
- [Sway] When did you do some
of these pieces right here?
- '94, '95
Most of these
- Okay what's this?
You got a blue ribbon on this one.
- [Kanye] That's cause I won.
- [Sway] Congratulations
- I remember this.
I was really into anime and Japanese art.
- [Sway] This one is kind of eerie.
- It was a good exercise
that the teacher gave us.
And it's not very good
but since it was a dude
looking like he was dead,
I just put my name on
it and put 1977 to 1995,
which is the year which
I actually drew it.
And somebody should have killed me
for how bad this actually was but..
- But this is almost like
a premonition of a sort
because you know, you were like this
at the end of your car accident.
You were in the bed like this
and you thought it was your deathbed.
- Right, so I would never
draw myself dead ever again.
- [Sway] You ever find
time to do this anymore?
- Seldomly.
Now drawing, I just use it as a language.
Like I want it to look like (scats) this.
I love to draw but I just love music more.
See my thing about the drawings is,
I couldn't turn 'em up louder.
I wanted to do something
where people have it on all the time
and basically now, what my
music gets is a soundtrack
to millions of people's lives.
You couldn't get that
feeling from art school.
I couldn't get it.
(bell rings)
- Number three.
Before writing his own music,
he produced music for
other stars like Jay Z.
- So I used to just take
the New Jersey transit
and I'd pack up all my stuff,
pack up all my dats and put 'em in a bag
and just walk over here to Baseline.
And that was the key, right there.
Being able to walk up into Baseline
and play these rappers these beats.
I remember, it was Beanie Sigel's birthday
and I came and I played
a bunch of soul beats.
Like, we had soul beats here and there,
but I had a bunch that I was building up,
just from the success of 'Can Be Life.'
I was like,
I need to make some more stuff
in this vein, right here.
So I'm playing Beanie some
beats and he get to smiling,
like, 'Yeah, it's hot.'
But he had to go , so I don't know,
he was going somewhere for his birthday.
So then Hov came in.
I remember he had Gucci hat on,
like the fisherman joint
and Hip Hop, my manager, who
definitely saved my life,
was like, 'Yo, play that one beat for Hov'
And it came on
(humming)
and he was listening to it like,
'Ooh this shit is crazy, right here.'
and then it got to the chorus
and the chorus is like,
♫ Ain't no love in the heart of the city
(hums)
And all he's like 'Ooh'
and doing his face like that then.
He's like play a next
beat, play a next beat.
I play another beat.
Listening to it like 'Yo man'
He was so fudu and everything
that Hov is saying is in stone
I will never forget none of these words
cause I'm off the train,
I'm from Chicago.
I got $10 in my pocket right now
and I'm just having the
opportunity to play these beats
so, I've had given so-called hit records
to everything up to that point.
But at this point, it's like I'm just,
this is like the moment of
truth of me, right here.
So I play another beat,
then I play another beat,
then I play this one beat and it was like
♫ Never, never, never, never change,
♫ I never change.
Yo, he took his hat down, he's like ooh.
I was like yo, maybe he like 'em.
Maybe Hov might buy this beat.
So he was like, 'Yo,
put them joints on CD'
and then he left out right.
I was like, 'Ok I'll
put these joints on CD
'and we goin' see what happen'
So then two weeks later, the
Blueprint was finished right,
so basically at that point,
everything started rolling.
Everybody's like,
'Yo man I heard you had
half the Blueprint album
'I heard you did half of Jay Z's album.'
I couldn't even believe it myself.
Now,
cause of Hip Hop, G,
the Blueprint and Dame,
I'm over here with the
opportunity to get my music out
which is what I wanted since third grade.
(bell rings)
- In 2002, he survived
a near fatal car crash,
which prompted him to
write 'Through the Wire'
- When I had my accident,
I found out at that moment
nothing in life is promised except death.
If you had the opportunity
to play this game of life
you need to appreciate every moment.
A lot of people don't
appreciate their moment
until it's passed.
(cheer)
And then you got to tell
those Al Bundy stories.
You remember when I..
But,
right now, it's my time and my moment,
thanks to the fans,
thanks to the accident,
thanks to God,
thanks to Rock-A-Fella,
Jay Z, Dame Dash, G,
my mother, Rhymefest,
everyone that's helped me
and I plan to celebrate.
I plan to celebrate and
scream and pop champagne
every chance I get cause
I'm at the Grammies, baby.
(bell rings)
- Number five, he announced in 2020,
that he's going to run for President.
- As you probably couldn't
guess by this moment,
I have decided in 2020
to run for President.
(cheers)
- I was actually watching.
I saw him do it
and I said, 'That's very interesting.
'I wonder who gave him that idea.'
Miley Cyrus said, 'I was
going to vote for Trump
'but now I'm voting for you.'
So it sounds like she
was all made up for me
and he took her away.
He's actually a different kind
of a person than people think
He's a nice guy.
(bell rings)
- Fact number six.
He has an amazing work ethic
and completely immerses
himself in his projects.
- I got to watch Kanye make
some of the last record.
Not the,
- Dark Twisted Fantasy record?
- Yeah, the Twisted Fantasy record, man.
And he lived it.
He was living it, man.
- When you say he lived it,
was he literally in studio
like a mad scientist,
every single day
- Yo man.
(inaudible) My man was in
the studio, kind of everyday,
First of all, I hope he doesn't.
You know, when Kanye get mad at you
then you get dissed on a record.
(laughs)
Nah I was just impressed.
First of all, everybody in
the studio had suits on.
Everybody.
- You're kidding me.
- I'm serious.
- Was that like a pre-req?
- Yo, I thought he had
flown in the bunch of guys
from Europe or something.
But all the engineers and
everybody was in black suits
and white shirts and black tie.
He set up a mood,
that when you walked in
there, you felt this mood,
especially when you went
into electric lady land.
You felt like.
- That's interesting.
- Yeah he set a mood, man and then,
and you knew he was going to be there.
I stopped in there a few nights
and we did,
What did we do?
We did the 'Blame Game.'
- Wow that's interesting.
- But he, you know,
when you talk to him, he's living it.
- He's immersed in it.
- He's immersed in it and
when he does the fashion,
he's immersed in it.
(bell rings)
Fact number seven.
Kanye suggested that John
Stevens change his name
to John Legend.
- You used to be John Stevens.
- [John] Yes.
- It was Kanye West who
said, change to Legend.
- You know, the first person, actually,
was a guy named Jay Hivey,
who's also from Chicago
and is a friend of mine and Kanye's.
And he's a poet.
And we're working on Kanye's album
and Kanye was having
me sing all these parts
and Jay Hivey was just like,
'Man, we going to have
to call you the Legend'
cause my voice is kind of old school.
I've always had a old soul
and he just felt like
that name was appropriate
for who I was.
- Have you always known
you always had an old soul?
- Always knew I had a old soul.
(laughs)
When I was like seven or eight years old,
my Halloween costume was,
I was dressed up as a
businessman with a briefcase
cause I wanted to be
grown when I was seven.
(laughs)
I liked how my grandfather
carried himself.
I just wanted to be grown
when I was a little kid.
And then, Kanye was like,
'Man, you should just
call yourself John Legend'
and I was like, no, that's ridiculous.
(laughs)
You know, of course, Kanye's
got a new album called Yeezus,
so he's not afraid
to say big, bold things.
And maybe I'll just roll with
this whole Jon Legend thing.
(bell ring)
Number eight.
He filters his ideas by
speaking with thought leaders
like Elon Musk and Bill Knight.
- [Kanye] It's a difference
between somebody who working
for somebody else's idea
and a person who made the idea.
Cause me and Phil Knight
going to talk like this.
The way me and Elon Musk talk
for three hours like this.
The way me and Eric Smith talk like this.
This is a,
- [Interviewer] Who are
the people you just named?
- [Kanye] Elon Musk has
the car company Tesla
also has Space X,
also invented the hyperloop.
Eric Smith is the head of Google.
So I'm just saying current
civilization, living civilization
that can actually have a full conversation
about what it is I'm attempting to do.
So it's a lot of my ideas
that I put out in the world
have now then been pilfered
through by corporations
whether it's sonic ideas
cause Yeezus, at the end of the day,
you can like it, you can not like it,
but it's a group of new ideas.
(bell rings)
- Fact number nine.
He's won 21 Grammy awards,
making him one of the most
awarded artists of all time.
- I'd like to thank everybody
who's accepted me trying
to break new boundaries of music.
I wake up in the morning just thinking
about what stereotypes I want to break.
And we push the envelope
with the last album,
with 'Stronger',
with records that they thought
wouldn't play on urban radio.
And it's our responsibility as musicians
to keep pushing each other
and keep competing with each other.
It's a really great competition.
I see artistes like Beyonce, Alicia Keys,
Rihanna, Chris Brown, Chris
Martin all in the same room.
And we're going to push this music
to the point where it was
like in the '60's in the '70's
when you talking about Led Zeppelin
and Hendricks and the Beatles.
We will be the new Beatles
The new Hendricks.
They said any other industry,
you supposed to do better than the past.
The computer should
get smaller and faster.
But whenever you say, I want to be Elvis,
they say what's wrong with you?
But I want to be Elvis.
Everybody ask me the question,
they want to know, 'Well Kan,
'I know he's goin' wild out.
'I know he's goin' do something crazy.'
Everybody want to know what
I would do if I didn't win.
I guess we'll never know.
(audience cheers)
- Thank you guys so much
for watching this video.
Love to know what did you think.
Let me know.
Leave it down in the comments below.
What was your favorite surprising fact.
How many of them actually surprised you?
Are there more that you
want to add to the list.
Leave it down in the comments.
Thank you guys again for watching.
I believe in you.
I hope it gets you to believe
in yourself and whatever.
Your one word is much love.
I'll see you soon.
(bell rings)
Bonus fact number ten.
Walt Disney is one of his idols.
- I'm standing up and I'm
telling you I am Warhol.
I am the number one most impactful
artiste of our generation
I am Shakespeare in
the flesh, Walt Disney.
I mean, taste, culture,
art
just the quality of life.
This is what I'm here to do
so when I compare myself to
Steve Jobs or Walt Disney,
Howard Hughes, David Stern,
Michelangelo, Da Vinci,
Jesus or whatever it is,
I'm saying these are my heroes.
These are people that I look up to.
This is the type of impact
I want to make on the earth.
If I can make this type of
impact up to this point,
what can I do if, if
you call Bob Eichner',
and say, 'Yo, give him a shot.'
If you call Oprah and
say, 'Yo back this kid.'
This kid (inaudible)
his parents were educators.
He wants to educate.
He wants to look at curriculums and say
how to re-simplify that.
Exactly what I did in music,
I want to apply to product.
I want to apply it to education.
This is what my company DONDA is about.